jerry is with us in Branson Missouri hi
Jerry how are you we're doing fabulous
thanks to you Dave well we're honored to
have you on today what's your net worth
sir we're about 1.4 cool and what's the
mix on that what's it invested in the
mix is about 500 and IRAs and 401 K 350
and cash and non-qualified annuity and
about 430 in real estate okay very cool
and the the retirement stuff is that
invested in mutual funds no no part of
them are in guaranteed income for the
rest of our lives in case we live to be
90 we'll never have to work out with our
money okay and what was your average
income through your working life
basically 60 to 120 okay and how old are
you I'm 66 and how much of this one
point four million did you inherit I
inherited about one and a half just a
year and a half ago one and a half what
oh I sorry 150,000 150,000 just last
year yes okay so that did not cause this
net worth no no it just added a little
more giving other unfortunate people
cool gotcha and what was your career sir
I had two careers it's part of my secret
I worked for an aerospace firm and Delta
retirement for 37 years
and then I also ran an income tax
self-employed taxpayers us beside that
okay so my wife could stay home with the
babies not sure what's your degree in I
have an a a and business a a in business
okay so aerospace so you're not a rocket
scientist no I'm the guy that that
managed the buildings for the rocket
scientists couldn't resist alright okay
and your GPA when you were in school I'm
sorry Dave for four you broke the you
broke the mold okay that's okay I love
it and and what part did you utilizing
debt to your advantage
what part did that play
you building this wealth well I'll say
that's a little sideshow just my
personal residence that's the only thing
I borrowed money to increase my wealth
okay so really almost none all right and
what part does giving play in your plan
or has it played in your plan as you've
gone along building as well oh it's gone
along well we live in with biblical
principles and ten percent goes to
missionaries all over the world and as
we get more we give more crashing what's
the most expensive pair of blue jeans
you or your wife ever bought I'm average
there buddy 35 bucks okay very cool and
how many new cars brand new cars did you
buy prior to being a millionaire prior
to having a million dollars well I
didn't do right I probably had eight
plus new cars that I leased but my
second job allowed me the budget to
afford that Junction okay all right so
you've done a lot of new cars all right
so of the 1.4 million how much of it did
you steal from somebody oh my goodness I
give it away I don't steal it just
making sure because some people think
all millionaires are crooks so I thought
I'd just ask
well I my heart is in it disadvantage
people when I see a sad story we step up
and we honor and help them yeah very
cool well we see a high correlation
between generous people and people that
are able to build wealth there seems to
be this natural connection there and the
generosity happens before the wealth
typically not after so I mean it
continues but it's not it is seems to be
the cause rather than the result so as
we study the statistics on this so talk
to the 25 year old version of you tell
them how you did this well I'll share
what my dad told me and it was kind of a
somewhere in between and that is after
you pay your bills your home your food
your groceries and and clothes and
whatever you've got the money leftover
discretional income and with that
discretion of all he said listen blow
half of it
save half of it and give 10% of all of
it so it was he said if you get my age
and you want a boat when he got that age
he died of a stroke and so he was right
he lived to become the age he wanted to
do something and he couldn't do it so he
said do it along the way so don't don't
starve yourself to death but have a
little fun but be sure and save that 15%
for your 401ks and your IRAs because
that is the key to the whole process so
you didn't live on beans and rice your
whole life you've enjoyed your life yeah
we were fortunate we didn't have to live
on beans and rice but you know we didn't
eat well until we were gosh 50s you know
it's on our young age you know but we
could eat out once a week maybe you know
at a very low cost restaurant very cool
well Jerry your great American success
story sir I'm honored to talk to you
thank you for sharing your millionaire
story on our millionaire theme ale hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show I
want to write a song I want to own my
own business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish